We've created a list using the square brackets
that contains 5 strings.
Each one is a 1-letter string spelling out the word "Hello."
And we've stored that in the variable p.
We could do the same thing we did with strings.
We could reassign p to a new value.
And if we did that, that would create a new list
containing the letters Y-E-L-L-O
and assign that to the variable p.
What we're going to do instead is mutate the list that we already created,
and we can do that by modifying the value of its elements.
Here we have an assignment where on the left side of the assignment
we have p[0].
This means select from the list that p refers to.
Find position 0.
Instead of getting the value at that position, though,
since it's on the left side of an assignment now,
we're going to replace that value with what's on the right side of the assignment,
in this case, the string containing the single letter y.
Let's see what that looks like.
When we created the list initially,
we had a list like this, and I'm going to draw the list showing boxes.
This is a list.
Each box is 1 element of the list,
and after the initial assignment, the value p refers to is this list.
Now when we do the assignment where p[0] is on the left side,
well, p[0] will find this position.
The assignment will replace what's there.
So, replace the H with the Y.
Note that we did not create a new list.
P still refers to the same list. We didn't have to change the arrow.
But we've changed the value of that list.
Let's try this in the Python interpreter.
I've created a list with the elements being 5 strings
spelling out the word "Hello."
And I can see that that's the value of p.
Now I'm going to use the assignment expression
to replace the value in the first element
and print p again.
Now when we run, we see that for the first print
the value of p is Hello.
For the second print, the value of p is Yellow.
We can change other values the same way,
so now we've changed the value in position 4
to an exclamation point, and we can see
the third line printed out.
We have "Yell!"